This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The Orange County Courthouse in Santa Ana, California, is a large granite and sandstone building from the early 20th century. It has Romanesque arches out front. Inside, there's a courtroom, some uninspiring conference rooms, and elaborate wrought iron staircases. Last year, Jennifer Birch found herself underneath it all, standing in the courthouse basement. It was like kind of a half basement, they had little windows.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。位于加利福尼亚州圣安娜的奥兰治县法院是一座建于20世纪初的大型花岗岩和砂岩建筑。它的正面有罗马式拱门。内部有一个法庭、一些平淡无奇的会议室和精致的锻铁楼梯。去年，詹妮弗·伯奇发现自己身处这一切之下，站在法院的地下室里。那就像是一个半地下室，他们有一些小窗户。
It reminded me of a room that Indiana Jones might be in or something like, you know, like it was very historical feeling and like, okay, let's not touch anything. The Indiana Jones style room that Jennifer stepped into was the Orange County Historical Archives. Jennifer was there doing research for a group called Moms Demand Action. It's an organization that advocates for gun control and regulation.
这让我想起了一个印第安纳·琼斯可能会待的房间，或者类似的地方，你知道，感觉非常有历史感，就像是，好吧，我们什么都别碰。詹妮弗走进的那个印第安纳·琼斯风格的房间是奥兰治县历史档案馆。詹妮弗在那里为一个叫“妈妈要求行动”的组织做研究。这是一个倡导枪支管制和监管的组织。
Not all the members are actually moms. Oh no, not at all. I work alongside men, students. But the thing they all have in common is that they care about gun control, which is exactly why Jennifer was in the courthouse that day. Moms Demand Action had dispatched volunteers
并非所有成员都是妈妈。哦不，完全不是。我和男士、学生们并肩工作。但他们共同点是都关心枪支管制，这正是詹妮弗那天在法院的原因。“妈妈要求行动”派遣了志愿者
like Jennifer to courthouse basements and local archives all over the country to dig up some of the oldest, most overlooked gun laws in the nation's history. And their goal, ultimately, was to fact check the highest court in the nation. Basically, moms demand action thought the Supreme Court got it wrong. That's reporter Gabrielle Burbae. And not just in the content of the decision. The mom suspected that a key historical fact
像詹妮弗一样，前往全国各地的法院地下室和地方档案馆，挖掘全国历史上最古老、最被忽视的枪支法律。他们的最终目标是核实全国最高法院的事实。基本上，“妈妈要求行动”认为最高法院搞错了。那是记者加布里埃尔·伯贝。不仅仅是在裁决的内容上。妈妈们怀疑一个关键的历史事实
used to decide one of the biggest gun cases in American history was just straight up factually inaccurate. The case in question was a landmark case from 2021 called New York State Rifle and Pistol Association Incorporated versus Bruin. If you're a legal nerd, you probably know this case, because it is a big one. The case dealt with some gun owners who had been denied permits to carry concealed firearms
被用来决定美国历史上最大的枪支案件之一，在事实上是完全不准确的。这个案件是2021年一个名为“纽约州步枪和手枪协会诉布鲁恩案”的里程碑式案件。如果你是个法律迷，你可能知道这个案子，因为它非常重要。该案涉及一些被拒绝发放隐蔽携带枪支许可证的枪支所有者
in New York State. The question of the case was whether a gun owner needs special circumstances for self-protection — something like a restraining order — to carry a gun hidden on their person. The court ended up siding with the gun owners, essentially saying that most people should be able to carry concealed firearms if that's what they want to do. This was a huge decision. It blew the top off gun restrictions across the country. But there was one thing in particular about the ruling that caught the attention of Mom's
在纽约州。案件的问题是，枪支所有者是否需要特殊情况才能进行自我保护——比如限制令——才能在身上隐蔽携带枪支。法院最终站在了枪支所有者一边，本质上是说，如果大多数人想这样做，他们应该能够隐蔽携带枪支。这是一个巨大的决定。它彻底打破了全国各地的枪支限制。但裁决中有一点特别引起了“妈妈要求行动”的注意。
Demand Action. They were fixated on how the court explained its decision. In this case, the justices hinged their decision on one key historical fact. Justice Clarence Thomas wrote the concurring opinion, and he said that by and large, there were no laws about who can carry a concealed weapon passed before the year 1900.
他们专注于法院如何解释其决定。在这个案件中，大法官们的决定取决于一个关键的历史事实。克拉伦斯·托马斯大法官撰写了协同意见书，他说，总的来说，在1900年之前，没有关于谁可以隐蔽携带武器的法律。
And because of that, concealed carry laws are not part of the, quote, history and tradition of the United States. —Mama's Demand Action looked at that fact and basically called bullsh—. They believed that someone in the history of the United States must have tried to regulate concealed carry before 1900. And they believed this could make a difference in future gun cases elsewhere in the country. So they set about proving it. — So down in the Santa Ana courthouse, Jennifer Birch started from the beginning.
正因为如此，隐蔽携带法律不属于美国所谓的“历史和传统”。——“妈妈要求行动”看了那个事实，基本上称之为胡扯。他们认为，在美国历史上，肯定有人在1900年之前试图监管隐蔽携带。他们认为这可能会对全国未来其他枪支案件产生影响。所以他们着手证明这一点。——所以在圣安娜法院，詹妮弗·伯奇从头开始。
Ordinances from the 1800s. — I opened the book and the pages were old, the writing was very, it was difficult to read, the cursive was real. — The archivist gave her some white gloves so she wouldn't smudge the paper. And I'm turning these pages which feel very brittle. The first couple, ordinance number one would be like, here's when we're going to meet as board of supervisors and then here's some things related to where you would put your horse and things like that. So I'm flipping through this going, I really don't know what I'm going to find. This definitely sounds like the Wild West. But when I first
1800年代的条例。——我打开书，书页很旧，字迹非常，很难读，是真正的草书。——档案管理员给了她一些白手套，这样她就不会弄脏纸张。我翻着这些感觉非常脆弱的页面。前几页，第一号条例就像是，这是我们作为监事会开会的时间，然后是一些关于你把马放在哪里的相关事项等等。所以我翻着这些，心想，我真的不知道我会发现什么。这绝对听起来像狂野西部。但当我第一次
saw the words concealed weapon in the ordinance, I thought, this is what we're looking for. My jaw, I'm sure, dropped and I may have gasped. My jaw, I'm sure, dropped and I may have gasped. What Jennifer found was a law passed in 1892 that said people in Santa Ana could not carry concealed weapons. It was a law showing that, despite what Justice Thomas claimed, concealed carry bans were in fact part of the history and tradition of the United States. And I felt like when I first saw that, not only did my heart rate go up a little bit,
在条例中看到“隐蔽武器”这几个字时，我想，这就是我们要找的。我的下巴肯定掉了下来，我可能倒吸了一口凉气。我的下巴肯定掉了下来，我可能倒吸了一口凉气。詹妮弗发现的是1892年通过的一项法律，该法律规定圣安娜的人们不得携带隐蔽武器。这是一项法律，表明尽管托马斯大法官声称，隐蔽携带禁令实际上是美国历史和传统的一部分。我觉得当我第一次看到那个时，不仅我的心率加快了一点，
but it did feel not to be overly dramatic, but I felt like I was hearing their voices, like their words coming at me from history. Like, this is remarkable. They cared about it. They cared about it a lot. The court said that apart from a few outlying laws, the U.S. did not stop people from carrying concealed weapons for the purpose of self-defense, at least not before 1900.
而且感觉并不想过于戏剧化，但我感觉我听到了他们的声音，就像他们的话从历史中向我袭来。就像，这太了不起了。他们关心这个。他们非常关心。法院说，除了少数例外法律外，美国并没有阻止人们为了自卫而隐蔽携带武器，至少在1900年之前没有。
That was the big justification for the ruling. And yet, here Jennifer was, holding one such law in her gloved hands. And Jennifer and the other moms didn't just turn up one law. We went to the next county over and kept going because I thought there's so much that we could uncover. I'm going to keep going until I feel like I've exhausted every city that was incorporated prior to 1900. Across the country, they kept finding other laws.
那是裁决的主要理由。然而，詹妮弗却戴着手套拿着这样的一项法律。詹妮弗和其他妈妈们不仅仅翻出了一项法律。我们去了隔壁县，继续寻找，因为我想我们能发现的东西太多了。我要一直找下去，直到我觉得我已经找遍了1900年之前成立的每一个城市。在全国各地，他们不断发现其他法律。
We found it in every single place we looked. Small cities, large cities. What Moms Demand Action discovered is that one of the biggest gun cases in American history was decided based on some questionable data. But it turns out this problem is bigger than just that one case. It's's bigger than moms demand action. The Supreme Court has a long relationship with bad facts. In 2017, ProPublica analyzed recent Supreme Court cases for factual errors. They found that in 2013, Justice Kennedy claimed that DNA analysis in criminal cases can ID suspects
我们在每一个我们查看的地方都发现了它。小城市，大城市。“妈妈要求行动”发现的是，美国历史上最大的枪支案件之一是基于一些可疑的数据做出的决定。但事实证明，这个问题比那一个案件要大。它比“妈妈要求行动”要大。最高法院与错误事实有着长期的关系。2017年，ProPublica分析了最高法院近期的案件中的事实错误。他们发现，2013年，肯尼迪大法官声称刑事案件中的DNA分析可以识别嫌疑人
with perfect accuracy. Not true. They also found a case where Justice Alito said that 88% of all companies perform background checks. But no one is even sure where that very specific number came from. ProPublica's research even turned up an error in one of the most consequential voting rights cases of the 21st century. In the landmark case Shelby v. Holder, Justice Roberts cited data about voter registration rates. His numbers turned out to be straight up wrong, and those bad facts were then used to strip away voter protections.
具有完美的准确性。不真实。他们还发现了一个案件，阿利托大法官说88%的公司执行背景调查。但没有人确定那个非常具体的数字来自哪里。ProPublica的研究甚至在21世纪最具影响力的投票权案件之一中发现了一个错误。在里程碑式的“谢尔比诉霍尔德案”中，罗伯茨大法官引用了关于选民登记率的数据。他的数字被证明是完全错误的，而那些错误的事实随后被用来剥夺选民保护。
In total, ProPublica found seven Supreme Court decisions just in recent years where the justices got their facts wrong. Sometimes these mistakes didn't have much impact on the decision itself, but sometimes they do. Sometimes justices hinge their decisions on these facts. So how is it that the highest court in the nation can get their facts wrong, not once, but again and again and again. And what even happens when you prove them wrong? Well, okay, let me see if I can break this down. Pretend I'm like a high schooler. This is Allison Orr-Larson at William and Mary Law School.
总的来说，ProPublica仅在近年来就发现了七项最高法院的裁决，大法官们搞错了事实。有时这些错误对决定本身影响不大，但有时却有影响。有时大法官们将他们的决定建立在这些事实之上。那么，全国最高法院怎么可能一次又一次地搞错事实呢？当你证明他们错了时，又会发生什么？好吧，让我看看我能不能解释清楚。假设我像个高中生。这是威廉与玛丽法学院的艾莉森·奥尔-拉森。
And according to Allison, the way the Supreme Court makes its decisions has changed a lot over the years. I'm really interested in the way that Supreme Court decisions are made, and I'm particularly interested in the process that they use to make them. For a long time, the court operated under what was called legal formalism. Legal formalism said that the job of any judge or justice was incredibly narrow. It was basically, look at the question
根据艾莉森的说法，最高法院做出决定的方式多年来发生了很大变化。我真的对最高法院做出决定的方式很感兴趣，我特别感兴趣的是他们用来做出决定的过程。很长一段时间里，法院在所谓的“法律形式主义”下运作。法律形式主义说，任何法官或大法官的工作都非常狭窄。基本上就是，看看问题
and the question of the case in front of them, check that question against any existing laws, and then make a decision. That's it. They were just mechanically interpreting it like almost like a little law robot could do. Unlike today, no one was going out of their way to hear what economists or sociologists
以及他们面前案件的问题，对照任何现有的法律检查该问题，然后做出决定。就是这样。他们只是机械地解释它，几乎就像一个小法律机器人能做的那样。与今天不同，没有人会特意去听经济学家或社会学家
or historians thought. Judges were just sticking to the law books. Those wouldn't have been part of the litigation in prior years, like before the turn of the century, before like 1900. Because that's not what we thought the judges were doing. So it wouldn't make sense to brief them on that. The rationale for this way of judging was that if you always and only looked at clean, dry law, the decisions would be completely objective. But not everyone was buying that. Right about the turn of the century, there's a shift into more realistically confronting
或历史学家怎么想。法官们只是坚持法律书籍。在早些年，比如世纪之交之前，比如1900年之前，这些不会是诉讼的一部分。因为那不是我们认为法官在做的事情。所以向他们简要介绍这些是没有意义的。这种判断方式的理由是，如果你总是且只看干净、枯燥的法律，决定将是完全客观的。但并不是每个人都买账。就在世纪之交，出现了一种转向，更现实地面对
the fact that judges are filling in gaps and sometimes making law. Like their decisions can't be done by little robot judges. In the late 19th and early 20th century, a movement rose up to challenge legal formalism. They called themselves the Legal Realists. The Legal Realists were a group of judges and legal scholars who were of the view that social and economic and political considerations were always part of judging and that judges would just mask it or disguise it. That's Fred Schauer, professor of law at the University of Virginia.
法官正在填补空白，有时在制定法律的事实。就像他们的决定不能由小机器人法官完成一样。在19世纪末和20世纪初，一场挑战法律形式主义的运动兴起。他们称自己为“法律现实主义者”。法律现实主义者是一群法官和法律学者，他们认为社会、经济和政治考量始终是判断的一部分，而法官只是掩盖或伪装它。那是弗雷德·肖尔，弗吉尼亚大学法学教授。
He says the realists felt that the justices weren't actually as objective as they said they were. Supreme Court justices were often making decisions based on their own political views, their own economic views, and would disguise it in the language of precedents or earlier decisions. Basically, what the realists said is that judges and justices may be trying to act like robots, but they're humans with their own lived experiences and assumptions about the world.
他说，现实主义者认为大法官们实际上并不像他们所说的那样客观。最高法院大法官们经常根据自己的政治观点、经济观点做出决定，并会用先例或早期决定的语言来伪装它。基本上，现实主义者所说的是，法官和大法官们可能试图表现得像机器人，但他们是拥有自己生活经验和对世界假设的人类。
And they brought those things into the courtroom whether they wanted to or not. The realists said, let's just accept that reality and try to balance it out. They wanted to arm the judges with more information so those judges could make more informed decisions. Holmes, a precursor of the realists. That's justice Oliver Wendell Holmes. Said, the life of the law has not been logic, it has been experience.
无论他们是否愿意，他们都把这些东西带进了法庭。现实主义者说，让我们接受那个现实并尝试平衡它。他们想用更多的信息武装法官，以便这些法官能做出更明智的决定。霍姆斯，现实主义者的先驱。那是奥利弗·温德尔·霍姆斯大法官。他说，法律的生命不是逻辑，而是经验。
He was talking about what human beings know by being part of the world, including what judges know by being part of the world. What motivated that movement? Like, did something happen or what was driving that? I mean, the conventional wisdom is that a big change was the so-called Brandeis brief. For a long time, the debate between the realists and the formalists had been mostly theoretical. That is, until the arrival of the Brandeis brief. The Brandeis brief came during a pivotal court case in the early 20th century.
他谈论的是人类作为世界的一部分所知道的东西，包括法官作为世界的一部分所知道的东西。是什么推动了那场运动？比如，发生了什么事，或者是什么在驱动它？我的意思是，传统智慧是，一个巨大的变化是所谓的“布兰代斯摘要”。很长一段时间里，现实主义者和形式主义者之间的辩论大多是理论上的。直到“布兰代斯摘要”的到来。“布兰代斯摘要”出现在20世纪初一个关键的法庭案件中。
And the man at the center of that case was a legal realist and progressive reformer named Louis Brandeis. He was a quite prominent practicing lawyer in private practice located in Boston. If the name Brandeis University means anything to you, this is the guy it was named after. He was very involved in a range of, let's call them, progressive policy issues. A lot of cases involving labor law, a lot of cases involving other aspects of employment law. As a young, zealous lawyer, Brandeis fought against the biggest railway monopoly to keep the Boston Common as a space for the people. He fought for better life insurance for all Americans,
而那个案件的核心人物是一位名叫路易斯·布兰代斯的法律现实主义者和进步改革者。他是波士顿一家私人执业的相当著名的执业律师。如果“布兰代斯大学”这个名字对你有什么意义，这就是它以之命名的人。他非常参与一系列，我们称之为进步政策的问题。许多涉及劳动法的案件，许多涉及就业法其他方面的案件。作为一名年轻、热情的律师，布兰代斯与最大的铁路垄断作斗争，以保持波士顿公园作为人民的空间。他为所有美国人争取更好的寿险，
and he would take a lot of these cases pro bono. Around Boston, he became known as the People's Attorney. And then in 1907, Brandeis set in motion a shift that would, for better and worse, change the inner workings of the highest court in the nation. It all started when he agreed to argue a labor case in front of the Supreme Court. A case called Mueller versus Oregon, in which Oregon had a bunch of laws designed to make workplace accommodations for women that was challenged by employers. Brandeis was representing Oregon, which meant he was arguing on behalf of the women and
他会无偿处理许多这些案件。在波士顿周围，他被称为“人民的律师”。然后在1907年，布兰代斯启动了一个转变，无论好坏，都将改变全国最高法院的内部运作。这一切始于他同意在最高法院面前辩论一个劳动案件。一个名为“穆勒诉俄勒冈案”的案件，其中俄勒冈州有一堆旨在为女性提供工作场所便利的法律，受到了雇主的挑战。布兰代斯代表俄勒冈州，这意味着他代表女性和
against their employers. Brandeis argued in a way that we would now think of as unfashionable, that because of the economic and physical weakness of women, it was necessary to have laws protecting them against the exploitation of employers. Here's Allison Orr-Larson again. You would be like, wow, that's all just sexist stereotyping and not like hard science. But it was 1908. As part of arguing the case, lawyers on both sides submitted their briefs.
反对她们的雇主。布兰代斯以我们现在认为过时的方式辩论，即由于女性在经济和身体上的弱点，有必要制定法律保护她们免受雇主的剥削。这是艾莉森·奥尔-拉森。你会说，哇，那全是性别歧视的刻板印象，而不是硬科学。但那是1908年。作为辩论案件的一部分，双方的律师提交了他们的摘要。
It's basically a write-up of their client's side of the story and any relevant laws. No facts about the real world. But rather than writing the typical brief, Brandeis went in a completely different direction. Instead of just including the basic dry legal precedent, he filled his brief with over 100 pages of facts that he thought should be present in the courtroom. And in this case, it was called Mueller versus Oregon, Brandeis files a brief and it only
这基本上是他们客户故事的一面之词和任何相关法律的摘要。没有关于现实世界的事实。但布兰代斯没有写典型的摘要，而是走向了一个完全不同的方向。他没有只包括基本的枯燥法律先例，而是用他认为应该出现在法庭上的100多页事实填满了他的摘要。在这个案件中，它被称为“穆勒诉俄勒冈案”，布兰代斯提交了一份摘要，它只有
has two pages of legal argument and that it has 102 pages of factual claims of evidence about how women needed special protection from the hazards of long working hours. In his brief, Brandeis included medical reports, statistics, psychology studies, all showing that long working hours affected the, quote, health, safety, morals, and general welfare of women. What would have been considered at the time, not very much law and a great deal of sociological, economic, and related facts. Many of those facts have actually been debunked. But the sort of pioneering part of that brief was the boldness of adding facts to the record,
两页的法律论点，而它有102页关于女性如何需要特殊保护免受长时间工作危害的事实主张证据。在摘要中，布兰代斯包括了医疗报告、统计数据、心理学研究，所有这些都表明长时间工作影响了女性所谓的“健康、安全、道德和普遍福利”。在当时会被认为没有多少法律，而有大量的社会学、经济学和相关事实。其中许多事实实际上已经被揭穿了。但该摘要那种开创性的部分是向记录中添加事实的胆量，
of making claims that aren't legal arguments, but are claims about the state of the world. And that's a definite change. It was a change in terms of the emphasis on facts as opposed to law. Brandeis was the first lawyer to go before the Supreme Court and say, hey, justices, you need to consider facts on the ground when you make decisions. Don't just look at the law. Basically, he was asking them to understand facts about how the world works to make better legal decisions.
做出不是法律论点，而是关于世界状态的主张。这是一个明确的变化。这是在强调事实而非法律方面的变化。布兰代斯是第一位在最高法院面前说，嘿，大法官们，你们在做决定时需要考虑实地事实的律师。不要只看法律。基本上，他要求他们理解关于世界如何运作的事实，以做出更好的法律决定。
Brandeis took a risk in submitting the brief, and it paid off. The justices read the brief and all the information he had provided, and they ruled in the women's favor. The fact that Brandeis won made it even more respectable to write a brief like this. Fred is quick to say that the Brandeis brief didn't suddenly override an entire century of legal tradition. But it did crack the door open for these outside facts to enter the court. This is all gradual. The way in which the use of sources changes rarely is dramatic. It's usually somebody does it, they get away with it, and then it becomes more respectable.
布兰代斯在提交摘要时冒了险，而且得到了回报。大法官们阅读了摘要和他提供的所有信息，他们做出了有利于女性的裁决。布兰代斯获胜的事实使得写这样的摘要变得更加受人尊敬。弗雷德很快说，布兰代斯摘要并没有突然推翻一个世纪的法律传统。但它确实为这些外部事实进入法院打开了一扇门。这一切都是渐进的。来源的使用方式的变化很少是戏剧性的。通常是有人做了，他们逃脱了惩罚，然后它变得更加受人尊敬。
Before this point, even legal realists wouldn't have written briefs that the justices might just ignore. But now, they basically had a stamp of approval. That stamp only became more official when Louis Brandeis himself was appointed to the Supreme Court eight years later. Over the next few decades,
在此之前，即使是法律现实主义者也不会写大法官们可能会忽略的摘要。但现在，他们基本上有了批准印章。当路易斯·布兰代斯本人在八年后被任命为最高法院大法官时，那个印章才变得更加正式。在接下来的几十年里，
legal realism completely transformed the court's landscape. Not only did it change the way lawyers worked, it changed the way judges worked too. Judges and justices started taking it upon themselves to read books and articles related to the cases that they were in the process of deciding, which today seems obvious. But this was all new territory. They would rely on published books of sociology and economics, occasionally published books of history. And the justices like it. Like they are hungry for this information.
法律现实主义彻底改变了法院的格局。它不仅改变了律师的工作方式，也改变了法官的工作方式。法官和大法官们开始承担起阅读与他们正在决定的案件相关的书籍和文章的责任，这在今天看来是显而易见的。但这全是新领域。他们会依赖出版的社会学和经济学书籍，偶尔出版的历史书籍。而大法官们喜欢它。就像他们渴望这些信息一样。
From the beginning, Brandeis and the legal realists envisioned the Brandeis brief as a tool to let them push forward progressive causes. And arguably, the biggest moment of triumph for that cause came with Brown versus Board of Education. Nearly 50 years after the Brandeis brief, the issue of segregation reached the Supreme Court. As part of the case, the
从一开始，布兰代斯和法律现实主义者就将布兰代斯摘要设想为推动进步事业的工具。可以说，该事业最大的胜利时刻出现在“布朗诉教育委员会案”中。在布兰代斯摘要发布近50年后，种族隔离问题到达了最高法院。作为案件的一部分，
justices set aside what they assumed about the world and read as much as they could about the psychological impact of segregation. And now, thanks in part to that outside information, segregation is unconstitutional. Or in Roe vs. Wade, where Justice Blackmun holed himself up in the Mayo Clinic Library in Minnesota to read everything he could about the medical science of abortions. None of that would have happened before Brandeis and the legal realists stepped in. There's no arguing with the fact that the Brandeis brief changed the game. It also did exactly what Brandeis hoped it would.
大法官们搁置了他们对世界的假设，并尽可能多地阅读了关于种族隔离心理影响的内容。现在，部分归功于那些外部信息，种族隔离违宪了。或者在“罗诉韦德案”中，布莱克门大法官把自己关在明尼苏达州的梅奥诊所图书馆里，阅读他能找到的关于堕胎医学科学的一切。在布兰代斯和法律现实主义者介入之前，这一切都不会发生。布兰代斯摘要改变了游戏规则，这一点无可争辩。它也确实做到了布兰代斯希望它做到的事情。
The brief let progressive lawyers pull a whole wealth of information into the courtroom so they could keep social reform moving forward. Which seems like a good thing. In a way, it does make sense to bring the justices down to earth from their high-minded, lofty legal theories. The realists thought they'd created a world where judges would learn the real facts on the ground and make better legal decisions because of it. But when the rubber hit the road, things went a lot differently than they imagined. And you wonder, do we want the justices just burying their heads in the sand and
该摘要让进步律师将大量信息引入法庭，以便他们能保持社会改革向前发展。这看起来像是一件好事。在某种程度上，让大法官们从他们高尚、崇高的法律理论中回到现实确实有道理。现实主义者认为他们创造了一个世界，法官们将在那里了解实地的真实事实，并因此做出更好的法律决定。但当付诸实践时，事情的发展与他们想象的截然不同。你会想，我们是否希望大法官们只是把头埋在沙子里，
not thinking about the context of their decisions, the decisions they make that are going to affect millions of people? No, I don't think that's a better world at all. But there's other things to consider in terms of who is telling them what and for what purpose. Here's the thing though. The Brandeis brief was, at its core, a tool. The progressives weren't the only ones who could wield it. While the reformers were out celebrating wins like Brown v. Board and Roe v. Wade, they had set in motion a change that would eventually derail some of their biggest wins. And at the center of that change was a thing called an amicus curiae brief, or amicus brief,
不去思考他们决定的背景，那些将影响数百万人的决定？不，我不认为那是一个更好的世界。但在谁在告诉他们什么以及为了什么目的方面，还有其他事情需要考虑。不过，事情是这样的。布兰代斯摘要的核心是一个工具。进步派并不是唯一能使用它的人。当改革者们在庆祝像“布朗诉教育委员会案”和“罗诉韦德案”这样的胜利时，他们已经启动了一个最终会破坏他们一些最大胜利的变革。而那个变革的核心是一个被称为“法庭之友摘要”或简称“法庭之友摘要”的东西，
for short. It stands for friend of the court. It's a Latin phrase. You'll also hear these referred to as amicus briefs, which is also right. These are briefs that are typically written by people or organizations who don't have any role to play in the case. They're not lawyers for either side. They just have an opinion about how the judges should rule and why. So they write an amicus brief saying how they think the case should go.
简而言之。它代表“法庭的朋友”。这是一个拉丁短语。你也会听到这些被称为“法庭之友摘要”，这也是对的。这些摘要通常由在案件中没有任何角色的人或组织撰写。他们不是任何一方的律师。他们只是对法官应该如何裁决以及为什么有意见。所以他们写了一份法庭之友摘要，说明他们认为案件应该如何进行。
Amicus briefs are pretty benign in theory. The idea is that they give perspective, research, or context about an upcoming case. Unlike regular briefs, where the lawyers in the case write in, these are written by people outside the case. Anyone, any member of the public, any organization can submit these briefs. All you need is a lawyer registered with the Supreme Court bar to help you file. The ones I think that are the most influential on the court are briefs that add facts, expertise, expertise that they might not get from the record below
法庭之友摘要在理论上是相当良性的。其想法是，它们提供了关于即将到来的案件的视角、研究或背景。与案件中的律师撰写的常规摘要不同，这些是由案件之外的人撰写的。任何人，公众的任何成员，任何组织都可以提交这些摘要。你所需要的只是一名在最高法院律师协会注册的律师来帮助你提交。我认为对法院最有影响力的是那些增加事实、专业知识的摘要，他们可能无法从下级记录中获得
or from the party briefing. In a way, amicus briefs are exactly what legal realists like Brandeis wanted. They're a means of getting information from the real world into the courtroom. Amicus briefs flowed into all the big cases of the 20th century. Roe v. Wade, Bush v. Gore. And slowly, over the decades, they became a fixture of the courtroom. Then, in 2003, came a case that pushed the amicus brief past its humble origins and into
或从当事方的摘要中获得。在某种程度上，法庭之友摘要正是像布兰代斯这样的法律现实主义者想要的。它们是将来自现实世界的信息引入法庭的一种手段。法庭之友摘要流入了20世纪的所有大案。“罗诉韦德案”、“布什诉戈尔案”。几十年来，它们慢慢成为了法庭的固定装置。然后，在2003年，出现了一个将法庭之友摘要推向超越其卑微起源并进入
the spotlight. The opinion of the court number 02-241, Grutter v. Bollinger, will be announced by Justice O'Connor. The case was a challenge to affirmative action at the University of Michigan, and as part of the case, amicus briefs poured in from interested parties. The justices heard the case, they read the briefs, and they made a ruling. In this case, upholding affirmative action. But here's where the game starts to change.
聚光灯下的案件。法院第02-241号意见书，“格鲁特诉博林格案”，将由奥康纳大法官宣布。该案是对密歇根大学平权行动的挑战，作为案件的一部分，法庭之友摘要从相关方涌入。大法官们听取了案件，阅读了摘要，并做出了裁决。在这个案件中，维持了平权行动。但游戏开始改变的地方就在这里。
When Justice O'Connor delivered her opinion in the case, explaining why the court cited the way it did, she mentioned one specific amicus brief that the court had received. It was submitted by members of the military in support of affirmative action. High ranking retired officers and civilian military leaders assert that a highly qualified racially diverse officer corps, drawn in large part from college ROTC programs, is essential to our nation's security. This was a big deal. For the first time, justices were showing that not only do they read these
当奥康纳大法官在案件中发表她的意见，解释法院为何做出如此裁决时，她提到了法院收到的一个特定的法庭之友摘要。它是由军方成员提交的，支持平权行动。高级退役军官和文职军事领导人断言，一支主要来自大学预备役军官训练团项目、高素质且种族多元化的军官队伍，对我们国家的安全至关重要。这是一件大事。大法官们第一次表明，他们不仅阅读这些
briefs, amicus briefs actually play a big role in helping them make decisions. So much so that they'll cite them in their opinion announcements. At the time, this military brief actually helped save affirmative action. When Justice O'Connor referenced specific amicus briefs in an official court decision, it sent a clear message. If your side sends the right amicus brief, that could decide the case.
摘要，法庭之友摘要实际上在帮助他们做出决定方面发挥了巨大作用。以至于他们会在意见公告中引用它们。当时，这份军事摘要实际上帮助挽救了平权行动。当奥康纳大法官在正式法院裁决中引用特定的法庭之友摘要时，它发出了一个明确的信息。如果你们这一方发送了正确的法庭之友摘要，那可能会决定案件。
So it was, in many ways ways like a debutante moment, a coming out party for the power of amicus briefs. I think that led members of the bar to realize, you know what, we really have a chance of influencing the court's decision here, and we need to think strategically about who we get to say what. So there's just a dramatic uptick, to think strategically about who we get to say what. So like there's just a dramatic uptick, like a dramatic growth spurt of amicus briefs.
所以，它在许多方面就像一个初次登台的时刻，一个法庭之友摘要力量的出道派对。我认为这导致律师协会的成员意识到，你知道吗，我们在这里确实有机会影响法院的决定，我们需要战略性地考虑我们让谁说什么。所以，法庭之友摘要出现了戏剧性的上升，战略性地考虑我们让谁说什么。所以就像有戏剧性的上升，就像法庭之友摘要的戏剧性增长。
It became clear very quickly that amicus briefs were powerful. But in the words of Spider-Man's late great-uncle Ben, power is a hell of a drug. If amicus briefs started out as tools for justices to help them understand facts about our world, they were now essentially weapons for both sides of a case. And the fact that amicus briefs were now an integral part of the court highlighted one tiny little design flaw. Namely, that there is absolutely no mechanism in place for making sure that anything in those briefs is actually true.
很明显，法庭之友摘要非常强大。但用蜘蛛侠已故伟大的本叔叔的话来说，权力是一种地狱般的毒品。如果法庭之友摘要最初是大法官们帮助他们理解我们世界事实的工具，那么它们现在本质上是案件双方的武器。而法庭之友摘要现在是法院不可或缺的一部分这一事实，突显了一个微小的设计缺陷。即，没有任何机制可以确保这些摘要中的任何内容实际上是真实的。
The dirty secret here is that the Supreme Court doesn't have any fact-checking mechanism for amicus briefs. None. There's no fact-checking for anything that the judges read to decide their cases. To be clear, there's a fact-checker for this podcast right now. These words right here are being fact checker for this podcast right now. These words right here are being fact checked. Hey, Graham. And yet for the highest court in the land, the court making decisions that changed the course of millions of lives, nothing.
这里的肮脏秘密是，最高法院没有任何针对法庭之友摘要的事实核查机制。没有。法官们阅读以决定案件的任何内容都没有事实核查。明确地说，这个播客现在有一个事实核查员。这些话现在正在被事实核查。嘿，格雷厄姆。然而，对于这片土地上的最高法院，那个做出改变数百万生命进程决定的法院，却什么都没有。
With the information overload following the Brandeis brief, the cart got ahead of the horse in a big way. But there is actually one thing standing between the Supreme Court justices and a firehose of sophisticated misinformation. And that is a bunch of overworked, 20-something law clerks. Oh boy, I was young. I think I was 27 years old. Allison was a law clerk under Justice Souter a couple years after graduating law school. And most clerks are around that age. The wacky part about it is you end up with pretty green young lawyers who are really
随着布兰代斯摘要之后的信息过载，马车在很大程度上跑到了马的前面。但实际上有一件事站在最高法院大法官和一股复杂的错误信息洪流之间。那就是一群过度劳累、20多岁的法律助理。哦，天哪，我当时很年轻。我想我当时27岁。艾莉森是苏特大法官手下的法律助理，在法学院毕业几年后。大多数助理都在那个年龄。古怪的部分是，你最终会得到相当稚嫩的年轻律师，他们确实
at the seat of power in the legal system. So you have access to the very, very top, even though you are brand new. As a clerk, Allison had a ton of tasks, like reading all the cases filed to the court, suggesting which ones the justices should take, helping the justices prepare for oral arguments, helping them write decisions. And on top of all of that, she and her fellow clerks also had to read amicus briefs and any outside information the justices wanted to know about. How did you know you weren't getting something wrong?
处于法律体系权力的中心。所以你有权接触到最高层，即使你是全新的。作为一名助理，艾莉森有很多任务，比如阅读提交给法院的所有案件，建议大法官们应该受理哪些，帮助大法官们准备口头辩论，帮助他们撰写决定。除此之外，她和她的同事们还必须阅读法庭之友摘要和大法官们想知道的任何外部信息。你怎么知道你没有搞错什么？
Um, you didn't. You can certainly do your own research for sure, but remember that there's limited hours in the day. So you're working very hard and under the time pressure of litigation. And there's only four law clerks for every chambers. So if you're a law clerk and you have five amicus briefs coming in, you might be able to fact check those or at least think critically about who's writing them. But in the biggest cases, the most high profile ones,
嗯，你不知道。你当然可以自己做研究，但请记住，一天的时间是有限的。所以你工作非常努力，并且在诉讼的时间压力下。每个办公室只有四名法律助理。所以如果你是一名法律助理，有五份法庭之友摘要进来，你也许能核实这些摘要，或者至少批判性地思考是谁在写它们。但在最大的案件中，最引人注目的那些，
there are often hundreds of amicus briefs flowing in from all over the world. You have hundreds of these briefs on the library cart and you're asking young lawyers, really, to be able to identify the reliable ones from the unreliable ones. Sometimes that's possible, but sometimes it's not. So law clerks on a deadline are poring over amicus briefs. They're reading whatever outside research their justices ask them to find, and their job doesn't even technically include fact-checking any of it. And it's not that no one noticed this problem until it was too late, or that no one ever
通常有数百份来自世界各地的法庭之友摘要涌入。你的图书馆推车上有数百份这些摘要，你真的在要求年轻律师能够从不可靠的摘要中识别出可靠的摘要。有时这是可能的，但有时不是。所以有截止日期的法律助理正在仔细研读法庭之友摘要。他们正在阅读大法官们要求他们寻找的任何外部研究，而他们的工作在技术上甚至不包括核实其中任何内容。并不是没有人注意到这个问题，直到为时已晚，或者没有人
tried to solve it. In the 1980s, one man did try and propose the court do something about its fact problem. His name was Kenneth Culp Davis. Kenneth Culp Davis was a very famous law professor who taught administrative law. And Professor Davis's view was we should have something sort of like the congressionalional Research Service that helps the courts. Basically, an entire research department to help the court parse through all of these outside facts coming in through briefs and just general research. Kenneth went on speaking tours throughout the country preaching the need for real change in how the court educates itself.
试图解决它。在1980年代，一个人确实试图并提议法院对其事实问题做点什么。他的名字叫肯尼斯·卡尔普·戴维斯。肯尼斯·卡尔普·戴维斯是一位非常著名的法学教授，教授行政法。戴维斯教授的观点是，我们应该有一些类似于国会研究服务处的东西来帮助法院。基本上，一个完整的研究部门来帮助法院解析通过摘要和一般研究进来的所有这些外部事实。肯尼斯在全国各地进行巡回演讲，宣扬法院在如何自我教育方面需要真正变革的必要性。
It came out of a recognition that judges were looking at outside facts all the time and wanting to add some more discipline to that. What happened to Kenneth Culp Davis's proposal? Nothing. That is- Why not? Nothing. That is, courts are reluctant to sort of delegate their responsibilities to others. Judges are comfortable with their own knowledge, maybe too comfortable. Kenneth's proposal didn't get anywhere because the court thought that any fact-checker would
它源于一种认识，即法官一直在查看外部事实，并希望增加一些纪律。肯尼斯·卡尔普·戴维斯的提议发生了什么？什么也没发生。那是——为什么不呢？什么也没发生。也就是说，法院不愿将其责任委托给他人。法官们对自己的知识感到舒适，也许太舒适了。肯尼斯的提议没有取得任何进展，因为法院认为任何事实核查员都会
be too political, that no one could be objective enough to sort through and fact-check all the information that comes into the court. It's been about 50 years since the court rejected Kenneth's vision for reform, and the situation today is possibly even worse. Because we're not just dealing with the issue of what is in the briefs. We're also dealing with the problem of where those amicus briefs are coming from. The amicus briefs of today are no longer the quaint little letters we saw showing up after the Brandeis era.
太政治化，没有人能足够客观地筛选和核实进入法院的所有信息。距离法院拒绝肯尼斯的改革愿景已经过去了大约50年，今天的情况可能更糟。因为我们不仅在处理摘要中有什么的问题。我们还在处理这些法庭之友摘要来自哪里的问题。今天的法庭之友摘要不再是我们看到在布兰代斯时代之后出现的古雅小信件。
Now we have a certified amicus brief industrial complex. Lawyers today don't just wait for experts supporting their views to weigh in. They actively reach out to people or interest groups they want to write in and they'll dictate what precisely they want those amicus briefs to say. We call it amicus wrangler and amicus whisperer. So you need somebody who like recruits, you know what, it'd be great if we had a historian to say this, oh, you know what, we should get the military leaders to say that. And then you sort of coordinate the messaging so that the Supreme Court receives the information that you want the Supreme Court to receive from the people that you want endorsing those views. Those recruited amicus briefs might have good facts.
现在我们有一个经过认证的法庭之友摘要工业综合体。今天的律师不仅等待支持他们观点的专家发表意见。他们积极联系他们希望写信的人或利益集团，并会指示他们希望这些法庭之友摘要确切地说什么。我们称之为“法庭之友牧人”和“法庭之友耳语者”。所以你需要有人招募，你知道吗，如果我们有一位历史学家这么说会很好，哦，你知道吗，我们应该让军事领导人这么说。然后你协调信息，以便最高法院从你希望支持这些观点的人那里收到你希望最高法院收到的信息。那些招募的法庭之友摘要可能有好的事实。
They might not. They could be written in good faith. But again, they might not. Either way, hundreds of these amicus briefs flood into the hands of law clerks who have no capacity and no system for fact checking. And that is the information that the Supreme Court uses to make its decisions. And it's all a much more orchestrated dance than people otherwise believed. It's like Brandeis and the legal realists opened up the faucet to facts, and now we're drowning in them. The result of the amicus brief industrial complex
它们可能没有。它们可能是出于善意撰写的。但同样，它们可能不是。无论哪种方式，数百份这些法庭之友摘要涌入没有能力也没有系统进行事实核查的法律助理手中。而这就是最高法院用来做出决定的信息。这一切比人们原本认为的更像是一场精心编排的舞蹈。就像布兰代斯和法律现实主义者打开了事实的水龙头，而现在我们淹没在其中。法庭之友摘要工业综合体的结果
is that, in the worst case scenario, the side with more money can drum up more amicus brief industrial complex is that, in the worst case scenario, the side with more money can drum up more amicus briefs and that gives them a huge advantage. And even in the best case scenario, there's essentially an information deadlock. The court has a ton of very convenient facts from both sides, and in the end it's up to the justices and their chosen clerks to decide which facts to actually believe. The idea behind the Brandeis brief was that if only the justices could have access to all the background information they needed, they could make a rational decision. But more information doesn't necessarily solve the problem.
是，在最坏的情况下，拥有更多资金的一方可以制造更多的法庭之友摘要，这给了他们巨大的优势。即使在最好的情况下，也本质上存在信息僵局。法院从双方那里得到了大量非常方便的事实，最终由大法官们和他们选择的助理来决定实际上相信哪些事实。布兰代斯摘要背后的想法是，如果大法官们能获得他们需要的所有背景信息，他们就能做出理性的决定。但更多的信息并不一定能解决问题。
Because of this fire hose of information, there is always an amicus brief for the opinion that you already hold. What ends up happening today is that a bunch of parties send in amicus briefs, some which inevitably contain errors, and the justices end up cherry-picking the facts that align with what those justices value most. Which, in the case of our current court, is very clear. They are by and large obsessed with one thing. But then you look to history and tradition. If you go right to history and tradition. If we're looking at that history and tradition.
因为这股信息洪流，对于你已经持有的观点，总有一份法庭之友摘要。今天最终发生的是，一群当事方发送了法庭之友摘要，其中一些不可避免地包含错误，而大法官们最终会挑选那些与这些大法官最看重的东西相符的事实。这在我们当前的法院中非常清楚。他们总的来说痴迷于一件事。但随后你看看历史和传统。如果你直接看历史和传统。如果我们正在看那个历史和传统。
And the relevant history and tradition exhaustively surveyed by this court. The current court has put a lot of emphasis on history and tradition. And that means you have instructions from the Supreme Court to the lower courts, you know, go ahead and review all of the history of, for example, firearm regulations in this jurisdiction,
以及本法院详尽调查的相关历史和传统。当前的法院非常强调历史和传统。这意味着你得到了最高法院对下级法院的指示，你知道，去审查该司法管辖区内例如枪支法规的所有历史，
and come up with the history and tradition. So is that quest a factual one or a legal one or a little bit of both? I think that's a really important question. I think we're just now beginning to wrestle with it. This very specific, very consistent lens of history and tradition is what brings us back to the courthouse basement, where volunteers like Moms Demand Action have been looking for concealed carry laws in archives across the nation. Remember, the moms are trying to find evidence that the whole premise of the court's ruling in Bruin was just straight-up factually wrong.
并得出历史和传统。那么那个追求是一个事实问题还是一个法律问题，或者两者兼而有之？我认为这是一个非常重要的问题。我认为我们才刚刚开始努力解决它。这种非常具体、非常一致的历史和传统视角，正是把我们带回法院地下室的原因，在那里，“妈妈要求行动”这样的志愿者一直在全国各地的档案馆里寻找隐蔽携带法律。记住，妈妈们正试图找到证据，证明法院在“布鲁恩案”中裁决的整个前提在事实上是完全错误的。
And the Moms did find proof. Justice Thomas said that before 1900, concealed carry laws were not part of our history and tradition. And yet, Jennifer Birch and the Moms Demand Action volunteers found a ton of these laws in archives all across the country. But here's the thing. Here's the worst part. This information was sent to the justices in Bruin. Historians had written amicus briefs to the court
而“妈妈们”确实找到了证据。托马斯大法官表示，在1900年之前，隐蔽持枪法并不是我们历史和传统的一部分。然而，詹妮弗·伯奇和“妈妈们要求行动”组织的志愿者们在全国各地的档案中发现了大量此类法律。但问题在于，最糟糕的部分是，这些信息在“布鲁恩案”中被提交给了大法官们。历史学家们曾向法院提交过法庭之友陈述书，
already pointing out that concealed carry bans existed in the 1800s. It's just that you also had historians arguing the exact opposite. It's not clear what information was true or false in any of these briefs, or even which ones reached the justices. What is clear is that out of all of these briefs,
指出19世纪确实存在隐蔽持枪禁令。只是当时也有历史学家提出了完全相反的观点。在这些陈述书中，哪些信息是真实的，哪些是虚假的，甚至哪些信息真正传达给了大法官们，目前尚不清楚。可以确定的是，在所有这些陈述书中，
the justices made a choice about which pieces of information they took as fact. So you had historians on one side and historians on the other. So you had some historians saying, actually, there's a long history and tradition of regulating the right to carry out in the open. And then historians on the other side saying, nope, not at all. The right to bear arms has included the right to open
大法官们做出了一种选择，决定采信哪些信息作为事实。所以，一边是历史学家，另一边也是历史学家。一些历史学家说，实际上，规范公开持枪权的权利有着悠久的历史和传统。而另一边的历史学家则说，根本不是这样。持枪权一直包含公开
carry, and the New York law in question is an outlier. So it ultimately was up to five justices open carry and the New York law in question is an outlier. So, you know, it ultimately was up to five justices to decide which slate of historians they believed. So the amicus briefs kind of became a battleground of who gets to say what history is? Yes. So let's say that the justices do their factual research and then they get something wrong. They cite a source that has incorrect information, but then that's in the final decision. What happens when let's say they do nothing? Nothing.
持枪的权利，而涉案的纽约法律是一个特例。所以最终还是由五位大法官来决定他们相信哪一派历史学家的说法。所以法庭之友陈述书在某种程度上成了谁有权定义历史的战场？是的。那么，假设大法官们进行了事实调查，但结果却出错了呢？他们引用了一个包含错误信息的来源，但这些信息却出现在了最终判决中。如果他们什么都不做，会发生什么？什么都不会发生。
Okay. The short answer is nothing. Why? Why nothing? I think it was Justice Jackson of the Supreme Court who said we are not final because we are infallible. We are infallible because we are final. Yeah, that's so hard for me to, like, sit with. Somebody's got to have the last say, and very often judges have the last say. There are lots of things in the law and lots of things in the Constitution that we might now think of as
好的。简短的回答是什么都不会发生。为什么？为什么什么都不会发生？我想是最高法院的杰克逊大法官说过，我们之所以不是终审法院，并不是因为我们不会犯错，而是因为我们是终审法院，所以我们才不会犯错。是的，这让我很难接受。总得有人说了算，而法官往往拥有最终决定权。法律和宪法中有很多内容，我们现在可能认为在
politically or morally or even empirically wrong, but it's there. That's what makes it authoritative. That's when parents with some frequency say to their recalcitrant children, because I said so, because I said so is a big part of the law. In other words, there's nothing to say that the court needs to listen when faced with evidence that they got it wrong. In fact, it is not their job to worry about that. Their job is to make a decision and move on. These old laws the moms are finding, they can only really be used in amicus briefs
政治上、道德上甚至经验上是错误的，但它就在那里。这正是其权威性的来源。这就是为什么父母经常对不听话的孩子说“因为我说了算”，因为“我说了算”是法律的重要组成部分。换句话说，当法院面对他们可能犯错的证据时，并没有什么机制要求他们必须听取。事实上，担心这一点并不是他们的工作。他们的工作是做出决定并继续前进。妈妈们发现的这些旧法律，实际上只能用于
for the next gun case, whenever and whatever that is. The moms can't overturn Bruin or even guarantee that next time, their information will rise above the hundreds of other briefs to actually make it to the justices. And even if it does rise to the top, the justices can still choose to ignore it, which is precisely the problem. I think in some of these cases, the honest truth is they know how they want to rule and they look to the history to buttress their view or take down the other side. I think that's the sad reality.
下一次枪支案件的法庭之友陈述书中，无论那是什么时候或什么案件。妈妈们无法推翻“布鲁恩案”，甚至无法保证下一次她们的信息能从数百份其他陈述书中脱颖而出，真正传达到大法官们手中。即使真的脱颖而出，大法官们仍然可以选择无视它，这恰恰是问题的所在。我认为在某些案件中，事实真相是他们知道自己想要什么样的裁决，并试图从历史中寻找支撑，或者以此反驳对方。我认为这是可悲的现实。
In a way, this is the court re-deciding what our history is. And even though it is admirable for moms to be in action to be digging up these old laws, they're also playing by the rules of a fixed game. A game where the court decides what history is. So I asked Allison, what is the point? Like, why even do what they're doing? One effort might be to show how crazy it is to do it this way. Like, if you have a constitutional test that's steeped on history and tradition, and then you are the ultimate decision-maker on what that history is, are we forever bound by
在某种程度上，这是法院在重新定义我们的历史。尽管“妈妈们”采取行动挖掘这些旧法律的行为令人钦佩，但她们也是在参与一场规则已定的游戏。在这场游戏中，法院决定了什么是历史。所以我问艾莉森，意义何在？为什么她们还要做这些事？一种努力可能是为了展示这种做法有多么荒谬。比如，如果你有一个基于历史和传统的宪法测试，而你又是定义什么是历史的最终决策者，那么我们是否永远被
your view about what history is? Because that's like a tension that I'm not, I haven't, I've yet to figure out. Even though it might be futile, and even though nothing might change, what the moms are doing is proving that the court may be final, but that doesn't mean it's factual. And there is something to be said for setting the record straight. After the break, I talk with Gabby about the women behind the man behind the Brandeis brief. So we're back with Gabby Burbae, reporter of that story. Hey, Gabby. Hi.
你对历史的看法所束缚？因为这是一种我还没能想通的张力。尽管这可能是徒劳的，尽管可能什么都不会改变，但“妈妈们”所做的是证明了法院可能是终审机构，但这并不意味着它是事实的裁决者。纠正记录本身就有其价值。休息之后，我将与加比谈谈布兰代斯陈述书背后的男人背后的女人们。我们回到那个故事的报道者加比·伯贝身边。嘿，加比。你好。
So, Louis Brandeis is this pivotal person in the story because he was the first person to really open up the court and the justice's minds to considering facts about the real world when he wrote his infamous Brandeis brief. But you have some facts about those facts, right? Right. So, you know, we know from the story that Brandeis had this like mythical quality of being this person who changed everything about how the Supreme Court considered facts about the world when making decisions. But
路易斯·布兰代斯是这个故事中的关键人物，因为他是第一个真正打开法院和大法官思想的人，让他们在撰写臭名昭著的“布兰代斯陈述书”时考虑现实世界的事实。但你对这些事实有一些了解，对吧？是的。我们从故事中知道，布兰代斯有一种神话般的特质，被认为是改变了最高法院在决策时考虑世界事实方式的人。但是
while I was researching, I found out that Brandeis actually did not write this brief he is so famously known for, at least not most of it. Okay. So wait, so Lewis Brandeis did not actually write the Brandeis brief? Nope. So here's what I found. I'm going to set the scene. The year is 1903. Oregon State adopts a law that sets the maximum number of working hours for women who work
在研究过程中，我发现布兰代斯实际上并没有写出他那份著名的陈述书，至少大部分内容不是他写的。等等，所以路易斯·布兰代斯实际上并没有写“布兰代斯陈述书”？没有。我来还原一下场景。那是1903年。俄勒冈州通过了一项法律，规定女性在
in factories or in the laundry business at 10 hours a day. And this is an effort that's championed by labor reformers. And of course, it gets challenged by business owners and brought up to the Supreme Court. So at that point, a prominent labor rights nonprofit led by the woman named Florence Kelly wants to make sure that Oregon has the best lawyer to represent its labor case. And you know, at this time, Brandeis is already known as the people's attorney. He is fighting the good fight for the labor movement. And Florence Kelly, with the help of her chief assistant, recruits Brandeis to represent
工厂或洗衣店工作的最长工作时间为每天10小时。这是一项由劳工改革者倡导的努力。当然，它受到了企业主的挑战，并被诉至最高法院。当时，由弗洛伦斯·凯利领导的一家著名的劳工权利非营利组织想要确保俄勒冈州拥有最好的律师来代理其劳工案件。当时，布兰代斯已经被称为“人民的律师”。他正在为劳工运动进行正义的斗争。弗洛伦斯·凯利在她的首席助理的帮助下，招募了布兰代斯来代表
Oregon. But Kelly already has an in with Brandeis. And that is because her chief assistant at this labor rights organization is none other than Louis Brandeis' sister-in-law, a woman named Josephine Goldmark. So this is like a whole family of social reformers right here. Yeah, they probably have like extremely passionate Thanksgiving gatherings at the Brandeis home. Okay, so I assume Flores Kelly has Josephine reach out to Louis Brandeis, he comes to represent Oregon,
俄勒冈州。但凯利与布兰代斯早有渊源。因为她在该劳工权利组织的首席助理正是路易斯·布兰代斯的嫂子，一位名叫约瑟芬·戈德马克的人。所以这简直是一个社会改革者家族。是的，他们可能在布兰代斯家举行过极其热烈的感恩节聚会。好的，所以我假设弗洛伦斯·凯利让约瑟芬联系了路易斯·布兰代斯，他便来代表俄勒冈州，
and then Brandeis goes on to write this famous Brandeis brief, is that how that happens? Yes, well, he did agree to represent Oregon, and he did want to present this groundbreaking brief, but he doesn't actually do that research for this groundbreaking brief himself. He has his sister-in-law, Josephine Goldmark, the assistant who helped recruit him, do pretty much like all of the research for him.
然后布兰代斯就写出了那份著名的“布兰代斯陈述书”，事情是这样的吗？是的，他确实同意代表俄勒冈州，也确实想提交这份开创性的陈述书，但他并没有亲自为这份开创性的陈述书做研究。他让他的嫂子，也就是帮他招募他的助理约瑟芬·戈德马克，几乎完成了所有的研究工作。
Okay. Okay. That sounds familiar. Yeah, okay. Yeah, so Josephine and her sister, along with some volunteers, scour libraries all over New York looking for facts about how dangerous excessive working hours are for women. And they find all this data from factory reports, doctor reports, and all of this other information that is proving that long working hours are harmful to health. And in the end, they end up gathering together the research that would fill 98 out of the 113 pages of the Brandeis brief. So the irony is, like, so he's outsourcing 90% of the work of this case about how harmful
好的。这听起来很熟悉。是的，约瑟芬和她的姐妹以及一些志愿者搜遍了纽约各地的图书馆，寻找关于过度工作时间对女性有多危险的事实。她们从工厂报告、医生报告中找到了所有这些数据，证明长时间工作对健康有害。最终，她们收集的研究资料填满了“布兰代斯陈述书”113页中的98页。讽刺的是，他将这份关于过度工作时间对女性有多大危害的案件中90%的工作外包给了
excessive working hours are for women, and he's doing that to the women in his life and taking all the credit for it. It's pretty on the nose. Okay. But piling on even more irony to the situation, this brief that was known for busting the door open to facts entering the court was filled with a ton of facts that have since been debunked. So for example, Brandeis quoted this medical report that said women had more water in their blood and their muscles than men. And I guess somehow that like contributes to weakness. Okay.
他生活中的女性，却独占了所有功劳。这真是太贴切了。但更讽刺的是，这份以向法院引入事实而闻名的陈述书，其中充满了后来被揭穿的事实。例如，布兰代斯引用了一份医学报告，称女性血液和肌肉中的水分比男性多。我想这在某种程度上导致了虚弱。好的。
Which is not true. Yeah, I guess like I figured that one out. In the story, we talk about this as this unfolding problem that you introduce briefs and then there's all these facts. And then later on they need to be fact-checked. But it turned out that the very first brief needed to be fact checked. Yeah, from the beginning, it's like this was already a flawed experiment. It's not like it went off the rails later. But you know, okay, the bad facts of the Brandeis
这并不是真的。我想我明白了。在故事中，我们谈到这是一个不断展开的问题，你引入了陈述书，然后里面包含了各种事实。后来发现它们需要被核实。但事实证明，第一份陈述书就需要被核实。是的，从一开始，这就像是一个有缺陷的实验。并不是后来才偏离轨道的。但是，撇开“布兰代斯陈述书”中糟糕的事实不谈，
brief aside, Josephine, his sister-in-law, she did go on to continue fighting for labor reforms for women throughout the 20th century. She wrote a book called Fatigue and Efficiency, which argued that fatigue from overwork led to a decrease in efficiency. She worked with the Factory Investigating Committee of New York after the Triangle Shirtwaist factory fire. And she became kind of like known in the labor rights movement for backing up her ideas and her arguments with rigorous factual research about labor laws. So my argument will be to put forth a motion to change the Brandeis brief to the Goldmark brief. Okay. Motion granted. Thank you, Gabby. Thank you.
他的嫂子约瑟芬在整个20世纪继续为女性争取劳工改革。她写了一本名为《疲劳与效率》的书，论证了过度工作导致的疲劳会导致效率下降。在三角内衣工厂火灾后，她与纽约工厂调查委员会合作。她因用关于劳工法的严谨事实研究来支持自己的观点和论据而在劳工权利运动中闻名。所以我的论点是提出一项动议，将“布兰代斯陈述书”更名为“戈德马克陈述书”。好的，动议通过。谢谢你，加比。谢谢。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Gabrielle Burbae, edited by Kelly Prime. Mix and music by Swan Real. Fact checking by Graham Hayesha. Cathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kohlstedt is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of our team includes Chris Berube, Sarah Bake, Martin Gonzalez, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriela Gladney, Christopher Johnson, Vivienne Lay, Lash Madon, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Nina Potuck, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars.
本周的《99% Invisible》由加布里埃尔·伯贝制作，凯利·普莱姆编辑。混音和音乐由斯旺·里尔完成。事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙负责。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。我们团队的其他成员包括克里斯·伯贝、莎拉·贝克、马丁·冈萨雷斯、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、拉什·马登、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、尼娜·波图克、乔·罗森伯格，以及我，罗曼·马斯。
The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the pan- We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the... I'm just remembering that someone on the Discord said that, do you move six blocks north every week in which case you'd be in the Sierra mountains or something. Now headquartered six blocks north of downtown where we used to live in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our brand new
99% Invisible的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区……我刚想起Discord上有人说，你们每周向北移动六个街区，那你们岂不是到了内华达山脉之类的地方了。现在总部位于我们曾经居住的市中心以北六个街区的潘多拉大楼，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰上城区。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们全新的
Discord server. There are over 3,500 people talking about architecture, talking about the power broker, talking about all kinds of fun things. Please join us there. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Should I have a joke about despite she backing up her rigorous research about labor laws and I would say like despite the copious amounts of water in her bloodstream. Despite her watery blood. Extremely watery blood. Extremely watery blood. Yeah, despite all that water. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Discord服务器。那里有超过3500人在讨论建筑、讨论《权力掮客》以及各种有趣的话题。请加入我们。在99PI.org上可以找到链接以及99PI的所有往期节目。我是否应该讲个笑话，尽管她用严谨的劳工法研究支持自己的观点，但我会说，尽管她血液中含有大量水分。尽管她有水样的血液。极其水样的血液。极其水样的血液。是的，尽管有那么多水。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。